[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs soir
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet il s'appelle thinker view où
vous interview ce soir dans le cadre de
votre profession de votre sacerdoce qui
est si je me trompe pas journaliste
d'investigation journalistique ou
est ce que vous oubliez vous voulez vous
bien vous voulez vous bien oui on vous
avez compris vous présenter
succinctement stéphanie stéphanie
comment
journalistes
depuis maintenant 10 ans à peu près
et donc ça veut dire que je suis pas
attaché à une rédaction en particulier
je travaille pour plusieurs titres
différents il poursuit elle les sujets
dans lequel je peux publier aussi bien
dans le canard enchaîné mediapart ce
genre de choses que l'ops ça m'est
arrivé aussi l express bien sûr et voilà
jacques duplessis même punition moi
aussi journaliste indépendant depuis
2012 avant j'étais a fait un petit saut
à ouest france voilà mais moi aussi je
suis dans l'investigation je travaille
essentiellement aussi pour
paris-match mediapart de canard enchaîné
et marianne enfin un peu tous les
journaux il ya des cases enquête et puis
à côté de l'anc est tout aussi d'autres
choses sur la société cfi d'armes c'est
quoi alors mes faits d'armes
g33 arctique ont donné lieu à des
enquêtes au parquet national financier
viendra dessus après à votre gauche vous
avez antoine champagne bonsoir
moi je suis journaliste ceci indépendant
pareil donc voila comme mes petits
camarades je travaille pour à peu près
tous les tous les médias où il ya des
cases d'investigation et puis j'ai aussi
cofondé comme tu le sais un journal sur
internet qui sape le reflet pour info et
où on
on aborde des sujets plus techniques sur
les internets en effet là on reviendra
sur stéphanie d'un prêt pour les faits
d'armes aussi les faits d'armes ces
voix-là avoir révélé la vente d'un
système
d'écouté global pour tout l'internet en
libye par une société française qui
s'appelle amesys et puis voilà après on
a creusé le sujet en large et en travers
et je crois qu'ils les voir une centaine
d'articles reflets sur sur ces sociétés
reflet que hopley amesys cosmos etc
c'est un pro qui quelqu'un comme nation
alors non ils sont poursuivis devant le
pôle crimes de guerre crimes contre
l'humanité li tribunal de paris de
grande instance mais c'est pas c'est pas
forcément à cause de nous c'est voilà il
ya déjà eu des conséquences en fait la
vente de ce système il ya des gens qui
ont été torturés en libye sur la base
des écoutes qui avait été fait de leur
leur discussion sur facebook ou ailleurs
ont été interceptés et donc voilà par
une par une société française enfin
parler le matériel c'était française en
tout cas c'est fini
vous fait d'armes est bien comme jacques
j'ai 2 enfin j'en ai une deux mois on va
dire j'ai deux enquêtes au parquet
national financiers enfin deux oncles et
au parc c'est je suis à l'origine de
deux enquêtes au parquet national
financiers qui concernent des marchés
publics dans le dans le cotre contrôle
automatisé des infractions routières
dont des radars vous 3 la question vous
choisissez pour répondre si vous avez
combien de procédures bâillon au fait si
vous en avez subi combien
alors moi j'en suis à trois plaintes
j'ai tout gagné en première instance et
j'étais il ya deux jours pendant plus de
quatre heures à nouveau en cour d'appel
moi j'en ai j'en ai une qui s'est soldé
en fait par une erreur de procédure
l'avocat de la partie adverse le jour du
procès en fait il avait fait une erreur
de procédure et donc tout le monde était
là et on avait envie de l'aider parce
que on avait encore des révélations à
faire au procès ça nous amusait beaucoup
et bancs de paul poux procède donc a été
été suspendus a annulé pour raison d'une
erreur de procédure voilà
moi je paye de procédure de bâillon j'ai
juste eu un procès de la part d'une
entreprise qui s'appelait tati qui m'a
qui pensaient que j'avais pirater son
serveur web
donc voilà intrusion et maintien dans un
système de traitement automatisé de
données
voilà pourquoi tu regardes comme ça non
pour rien voilà donc je me suis retrouvé
en première instance j'étais condamné
assez légèrement à 3000 euros de
demandes avec sursis
moi je voulais que ça s'arrête parce que
ça fait quand même duré un an et demi
c'était cette histoire débile tout ça
parce que je m'étais promener sur leur
site avec un simple navigateur donc
l'aérien piratés
et puis bizarrement le parquet a fait
appel et pour demander ma relaxe
donc c'est reparti pour un tour et
effectivement le parquet a gagné puisque
j'ai été relaxé en deuxième instance ce
qui a fait une jurisprudence sur
le le fait de trouver des informations
sur un site alors qu'elle n'a à priori
pas dû être là enfin bon voilà bon eh
ben ça qu'on a fait les présentations
on vous reçoit aujourd'hui parce que
vous avez monté un collectif de
journalistes qui s'appelle intra muros
extra extra muros et merci et on vous
pousse des partenaires avec vous pour
vous lancer parce que vous faites un
documentaire d'investigation financé par
internet
qui commence qui dit quoi quoi ça
ressemble qui travaille là-dessus
combien ça coûte vous aller embêter qui
vous avez prévu des frais d'avocat vous
avez décidé de faire ça pour quoi
stéphanie
alors on va pas pour ça va coûter
combien ouest à pognon de dingue comme
on dit en ce moment ça va coûter cher
forcément l'investigation ça coûte cher
ce que ça prend beaucoup de temps sur
tout et ensuite on a quand même pas mal
de moyens en interne dans notre
collectif on est des journalistes
plurimédia quoi tu fais ça pour quoi
suzuki- mon père pourquoi tu as choisi
de te soucies pourquoi le faire
parce que c'est un sujet qui est jamais
passé à la télé
et qu'on a beaucoup de documents
beaucoup de on a des témoignages des
gens qui veulent bien parler à visage
découvert ce qui est quand même assez
rare sur ce genre de sujets un peu
compliqué où on parle quand même de
beaucoup d'argent public où il ya
beaucoup
de gros soupçons de conflits d'intérêts
va pas donner le sujet pour l'éditeur
qui une stratégie défensive en mars mais
y en a pour 1 po lyon c'est ça nous on a
évalué donc on peut quand même dire que
c'est ça concerne de l'argent public on
a évalué qu'il y avait une dépense de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros forcément
c'est plus de deux milliards d'euros qui
ont été dépensés et qui est qui ont été
dépensés pour
pour des prestations demandées à des
entreprises privées donc il ya des
preuves de tout ça ces sources et sait
caresser bétonner ses triomphes du mas
est ce qu on va tâcher de faire donc
effectivement ça prend aussi beaucoup de
temps par rapport à ça et on a des
métiers en fait pourquoi ça nous coûte
cher parce qu'on interne on a quand même
déjà beaucoup de compétences mais il ya
quand même des compétences qui nous
manque dans notre collectif notamment un
monteur par exemple on va faire aussi
pas mal d'animations et voilà jacques
pourquoi tu fais ça d'ailleurs beaucoup
tu es journaliste alors moi je suis
journaliste parce que c'est la moins de
bénédictin voilà c'est le moine
bénédictin non mais j'ai en moi
franchement je suis rentré dans ce
métier là parce que j'avais envie de
raconter un peu le monde moi j'ai
commencé en local et je me suis aperçu
que le journalisme ça pouvait commencer
tout près de chez soi et puis ensuite
bombe un petit côté
fouille-merde année j'aime bien aller
voir un peu lorsque j'en ai tout de
suite eu marre des conférences de presse
où on nous raconte ce qu'on doit dire
quoi voilà donc ça ça va tout de suite
gonflé et donc dès que j'ai eu des
possibilités de dès que j'ai eu des
possibilités de regarder apple dessous
des cartes bassamois sama ça m'a
passionné et donc j'ai commencé même en
local j'étais à laval pour ouest france
et voilà puis un jour on a un
agriculteur qui a débarqué avec un
énorme dossier en disant on marnac il ya
liquidateur judiciaire qui qui veut me
prendre mon argent pour honnêtement il
avait l'air un peu dingue mais en fait
il a filé sur il a filé un gros dossier
donc bon c'est fade et le dossier avec
un collègue et finalement on en a fait
une page dans ouest france qui par un
journal spécialement d'investigation
peux pas le dire voilà il a fallu
expliquer à la rédaction que c'était
important intéressant et finalement on a
fait une page spéciale pour raconter le
mec avait plus tôt il avait raison quoi
et moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse et d'un
côté il ya beaucoup de journalistes qui
fréquentent les conférences de presse
moi je suis heureux je dois en faire
deux parents est donc là derrière dit
beaucoup de gens disent qu'ils
fréquentent les
rédactions de presse qui coiffe les
conférences de presse voilà un feutre et
aussi les petits fours une chose mais ça
c'est ce que leurs méninges du jour
il y en a de moins en moins mais deux
éventuellement cédés lieu pourquoi pas
si on y rencontre des gens intéressants
conséquent des cartes de visite parce
que les sources elles viennent rarement
frappe à notre porte donc il faut qu'on
aille aussi dans les endroits on peut
rencontrer des gens avec qui on va
établir une relation de confiance et qui
un jour quand on aura une questions à
leur poser il nous répondrons ou alors
si un jour ils ont ils sont témoins d'un
truc ils ont envie de parler qui nous
appelle nous voilà et ça ça soit en
rencontrant des gens ça serait pas en
attendant qu'ils viennent à nous voilà
mais après il ya les conférences de
presse et l'autre le truc où les mains
qui nous disent voilà ce qu'on voudrait
que vous communiquer là dessus toi et
moi ça m'intéresse absolument pas
antoine oui pourquoi d'investigation
pourquoi sacerdoce et ne sais quoi c'est
une vocation oui c'est une vocation
c'est venu très tôt j'étais tout petit
j'ai
moi aussi j'ai commencé en fait dans un
journal a trait carré très très propre
jezebel puis qui s'appelle l'agefi était
un canard financier très financier et
donc on était vraiment sur les faits les
chiffres etc et puis bon
le temps passant je me suis intéressé à
d'autres trucs là
effectivement su assez vite venu à
l'investigation j'ai rencontré des gens
le canard enchaîné donc je commence à
écrire chez eux aussi voilà et puis
j'étais un peu dans les premiers sur les
trucs internet donc comme je le
regardais un peu les 2sous d'internet
j'arrivais à sortir des infos qui était
pas trop public ou expliqué des trucs un
peu complexe du coup et ça va amener
aussi à l'investigation récépissé a
effectivement c'est un sacerdoce pas ce
que c'est c'est pas un métier où tu fais
fortune c'est pas un métier où il
possible de garder son intégrité ou ne
subit pas de pression alors hein tu peux
garder ton intégrité mais ça va se faire
aux dépens de ta carrière
fa c'est mon avis on va après je suis
peut-être le seul à penser comme ça mais
je pense que tu
tu vas pas finir
avec une écharpe rouge à la tête d'une
rédaction et sur tous les plateaux de
télé si tu passes ton temps à gueuler
contre les institutions contre les
entreprises contre le sait pas quoi pour
expliquer ce qu'elles font travers
donc ouais voilà est-ce qu est-ce que
vous autorisez être très vulgaire ouais
vous autorisez oui
[Musique]
je suis infiniment désolés mais c'est je
vais prendre le l'engagerait de temps en
temps qui se baladent sur internet est
ce que pour être un bon journaliste il
faut fermer sa gueule et sucé
alors non pourquoi
votre un bon journaliste
non non je pense pas c'est tu veux ça
dépend tu te fais le métier du diable et
non du peu tu peux imaginer que il ya un
certain nombre ce qu'on appelle les
éditocrates qui passent leur temps sur
les plateaux à
donner leur avis sur ce que nous alors
qu'eux ils sont absolument pas
spécialiste du truc mais ils ont quand
même un avis et un avis autorisé
voilà donc eu effectivement probablement
il faut qu'ils serre des pinces et que
voilà hills et une bonne communication
avec avec beaucoup de gens mais
donc évidemment ils vont pas se fâcher
avec les gens dont qui vont pas raconter
des histoires qui fâchent mais de façon
nous on s'en est rendu compte il ya pas
très longtemps à une soirée qui
s'appelle trombinoscope où ils remettent
un prix en fait c'est les éditorialistes
les journalistes
éditorialiste en vue qui remettent des
prix aux politiques et vraiment on voit
on voit vraiment
c'est effectivement en fait c'est quand
même demande très différents entre nous
et
et ces éditorialistes ou finalement
l'idée c'est de devenir
confident pour récupérer parce qu'ils
récupèrent malgré tout quand même des
informations par sa teinte intermédiaire
mais c'est vrai que s'ils vont super pas
ils sont sous le robinet ils attendent
que ça coule voilà c'est ça c'est ça
mais voilà il ya il ya quand même voilà
ils savent y en a qui sont plus ou moins
courtisans et donc qui ont plus ou moins
d'informations enfin vraiment il ya
quand même quelque chose
nous a effectivement non
on a du mal à le comprendre mais mais il
n'empêche que c'est aussi comme ça qu
éventuellement on a quand même des
informations je dis pas que c'est comme
ça qu'il faut le faire mais il n'empêche
on peut pas dire non plus qu'ils n'ont
pas du tout d'informations mais qu il
faut il faut de tout pour faire un monde
voila voila tu vas avoir des faillites
au mit
mais c'est vrai comme tu dis qu'on a un
peu sous le robinet et mais quand même
ils vont aller chercher ils vont se
faire copain pour essayer de tirer des
antilles rumba commence eelv on dit en
vacances j'en sais rien mais dîner
déjeuner c'est évident et je veux quand
tu connais pas grand chose bon mais en
tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est le
problème c'est pas temps d'aller
récupérer cette information en
courtisant séduisant que ensuite
effectivement ils vont ils vont
finalement je pense ne pas franchir un
cap c'est à dire perdre en indépendance
quand même pour pas perdre c'est ça le
problème c'est que si tout d'un coup ils
disent quelque chose qui ne va pas
plaire alors à celui à ceux qui veulent
bien leur donner quelques informations
de temps en temps forcément on ne leur
donnera plus donc c'est un rapport
finalement qui est biaisé jacques oui
moi je donne un contre exemple le divin
pour dire la plupart des journalistes là
on parle de journalistes parisiens où la
plupart des journalistes en france y
sont en province il raconte la vie
locale j'ai dire quand on voit un bon
wesh wesh france premier quotidien
national c'est pas pour rien c'est un
journal qui est très enracinée que les
gens aiment bien on dit on parle de
défiance des journalistes eh ben il ya
un journal il ya le journaliste local je
revois moi honnêtement j'ai toujours
quand j'étais en local j'ai toujours été
apprécié par les gens et les gens y
croyaient et il y en avait des gens qui
me sert non mais c'est vrai je les lui
dans ouest france si ouais mais c'est
finalement ce n'est peut-être pas si
vrai que ça les gens y croyaient encore
il croit vraiment à l'information qui
dit ça veut dire quoi les joues les
joues les jours les lecteurs les lakers
les lecteurs des acteurs de ouest france
mais il nous disait et ils sont nombreux
quand il nous disait on croit ce que
vous écrivez et c'était une énorme
pression parce que vraiment les gens y
étaient attachés ils pensaient qu'on
rapportait fidèlement l'actualité locale
voilà donc non mais ce qui est vrai et
ce qui est vrai qu'on essayait de le
faire mais en même temps on peut pas
parler tous enfin on en attendait les
choix sur la locale bah ça arrive mais
c'est rare voilà mais ensuite quand on
dit le fait des fois de parler et à
parce qu'après on a plus d'informations
si on se cherche une source moi je
racontais quoi avec une institution
maman j'étais chargé des faits divers et
on apprend par deux les faits divers
c'est l'échec rising ouais ça va c'est
plutôt les vols violents fin voilà tout
ce qui relève foyer justice enfin voilà
et donc on apprend qu'il y avait un gros
malaise au commissariat de la valeur le
malaise au niveau du personnel il y
avait un commissaire adjoint qui
posaient plein de problèmes
bon on le raconte
du coup avant on allait voir moi tous
les jours j'ai passé au commissariat
pour raconter pour savoir s'il avait des
choses à vous raconter sur sur les faits
divers locaux à part du gros où je
raconte le malaise au commissariat ils
veulent plus nous recevoir
et en même temps du coup j'ai des
policiers qui m'ont contacté et j'ai
jamais eu autant d'affaires parce
qu'avant le commissaire et filtrer ils
disaient ce qu'ils avaient envie de me
dire mois après j'avais réussi à avoir
des sources dans le commissariat et donc
j'allais y j'allais voir l'ordinateur
ils me disaient les procédures en cours
de la journée donc j'allais j'avais plus
d'informations après après m'être fâché
avec l'institution qu'avant voilà et du
coup j'étais reconnu et mais qui me
disait ah oh moi toi tu as bien parler
de nous au moins tu as vraiment fait ton
boulot et voilà et du coup il me donnait
des informations avant que j'avais pas
alors tutu blanc sur une question qui
est très importante et kurt one va
récupérer
comment tu expliques cette défiance face
à la presse au journalisme comment la la
et comme pour reprendre les termes de
jacques les gens la population la france
d'en bas laissant dans
il exècre maintenant la presse c'est un
peu comme croque mort ouais je sais pas
si c'est comme croque mort mais bon
je pense qu'il ya plein de trucs qui
rentre en compte
la première chose c'est sans doute que
quand tu
sa part de très très loin je pense c'est
en fait tu as les rédactions aujourd'hui
limite au maximum leurs coûts en gros la
plupart des grands médias ont été
rachetés par des gens qui ont l'habitude
dans leur business habituel de faire des
chiffres importants c'est du 12 20 % de
rentabilité
d'après ce n'est pas ça donc ils
s'achètent une danseuse il se retrouve
avec un truc oui soit ils gagnent pas
d'argent soit très peu donc y mettre à
la direction de ces de ces entreprises
de presse des gens qui sont des experts
par exemple à triesman pendant un moment
il ya un gars qui est qu avait été
parachuté de chez l'oréal c'était un
cost killer il avait d excellent et puis
voilà il coupait là où ils pensaient que
ça coûtait mais sans se poser la clique
comme il connaissait pas les métiers
sans se poser la question de savoir
s'ils étaient essentielles ou pas donc
en gros tu te retrouves avec des
rédactions où il ya de moins en moins
d'argent pour leurs reportages pour
l'anc est donc et puis quasiment plus
personne qui part à l'étranger voir ce
qui se passe dans le monde
tu as
un turnover des journalistes ceux qui
sont encore embaucher dans l'action
c'est de moins en moins le cas de plus
en plus appel à des pigistes ça coûte
moins cher en charge donc ceux qui sont
dans les rédactions on s'occupe d'un
sujet et puis soit ils sortent de
l'école soit ils connaissent un peu le
sujet mais tout d'un coup on les met sur
autre chose donc ils redécouvrent un
sujet quelqu'un d'autre prend leur place
redécouvre le sujet d'avant et in fine
et quand un peu spécialiste d'un truc et
que tu lis un article dans un journal
sur quelque chose que tu connais bien
souvent tu dis en fait il ya des
conneries là s'est il raconte des
conneries dans cet article et après tu
te poses la question suivante s'il
raconte des conneries c'est un truc que
je connais si ça se trouve il raconte
des conneries sur tout le reste et donc
voilà tu as une espèce de défiance parce
que la qualité n'est plus vraiment au
rendez-vous stephen j moi non je suis
assez d'accord et je pense quand même
pour revenir aux éditorialistes
effectivement les chaînes d'info en
continu
font beaucoup de mal je pense à l'image
des journalistes parce qu'effectivement
on interroge des gens qui ont un avis
sur tout qui peuvent raconter plein de
bêtises parce qu'ils peuvent pas tout
connaître et il ya ce sentiment
effectivement que ils sont pas forcément
toujours très pointu sur les sujets sur
lesquels ils
répondent et en plus on a cette
impression effectivement qui copine
beaucoup avec le pouvoir en place et
c'est en l'occurrence vrai et six
copines pas ou si c'est ce que je disais
c'est à dire le problème c'est qu'à un
moment donné il ya un déséquilibre qui
secret
six ils vont trop loin s'ils ne vont pas
là où on leur dit d'aller et bien c'est
fini ils n'ont plus d'informations ils
n'ont plus rien donc quelque part c'est
terminé pour donc ça crée un vrai
problème ensuite pour pour le public
après tu as un billet aussi qui qui doit
être enfin qu'il faut pas perdre de vue
c'est en tout cas sur paris
la plupart des journalistes sont issus à
peu près de la même classe sociale et
ont fait à peu près les mêmes études
voilà et donc ils ont une vision du
monde qui est la même à peu près pour
tous et qui est pas forcément la même
vision que celle de des gens dont tu
parle et on l'a vu avec les gilet jaune
s'il ya un décalage total entre ce qu'on
voit à la télé et la réalité sur le
terrain des manifestations
moi j'ai suivi à peu près toutes les
manifestations tous les samedis et qu'un
appareil photo et voilà ce que ce que
j'ai vu c'est pas du tout ce que
j'entendais à la télé le soir entrons à
la radio dans la voiture donc il ya un
vrai souci voilà pendant un mois et demi
je me suis demandé si les rédactions
envoyer des gens dans les manifs ou pas
parce qu'on voyait pas la même chose en
fait donc il ya quand même un souci sur
les relations avec les politiques veut
donner une anecdote les politiques qui
pensent que les journalistes sont
prétexte on a bien vous faire ensemble
on va raconter ce qu'ils veulent moi je
suis partie un jour en libye en
reportage et donc on a une partie dans
un com l'aéroport était fermé à cause du
conflit on est parti dans un vol privé
affrété par le gouvernement libyen avec
un député français est donc dans l'avion
loi qui me raconte un tas de conneries
en fait ils connaissaient pas ces
dossiers du doubs du mix qui a
c'est jean frédéric poisson
voilà donc parti chrétien-démocrate et
tout donc il par là bas voir le
gouvernement de tripoli tout ça donc ils
commencent à discuter là et se présenter
à la présidentielle donc le grand scoop
enfants s'en foutait bon voila il
présenta présidentielle et puis moi donc
tu en as besoin de moi content quand il
va sauver le monde donc là il va
rencontrer le gouvernement libyen
africain a prévalu en syrie et puis ils
cueillent bientôt lui va s'occuper de la
paix sur la planète et tout et il
connaissait absolument pas et dossier
quoi donc et quand ça me passe de trucs
des islamistes des trucs mais quand il
savait pas qui était ou enfin bon et bon
effectivement mange bien dans l'avion et
tout et puis moi je suis un article sur
lui et je raconte c'est en fait il
connaît pas ses dossiers et où ils
m'appellent outre et en me disant mais
je comprends pas quand même le vin était
bon dans l'avion on était sympa on a
bien mangé
je comprends pas que tu aies pu dire des
choses méchantes comme ça sur moi comme
une nature rude y voit pas ce qu'on ne
voyait pas mais voilà mais que je dis
ouais mais les choses ne se passent pas
comme ça quoi c'est pas parce qu'on
parle gentiment dans un avion et qu on
est décontracté que voilà que moi je
suis pas mon boulot et on n'est pas
potes voilà il ya des politiques ils
pensent facilement parce que on a une
conversation décontracté qu'on est potes
et en local ce encore pire mon moi
j'étais à laval le maire de laval
rapidement de ces tutoyer bon et sous
prétexe on se tutoie jours je fais un
article est un peu méchant
ira quand même c'est pas sympa sur ce
que lâche ou mais méfions si ce n'est le
nom au factuel saisir je racontais
justement bourse est une histoire bête
tandis qu'ils fondent informatiques dans
des écoles mais en fait ça marchait pas
c'était pas opérationnels voulait faire
croire que c'est opérationnel donc moi
j'ai raconté que cette épopée
rationnelle et voilà et donc il n'a pas
aimé parce que c'était pas son plan com
et moi je le dis mais je suis pas pour
faire le plein comme moi je suis là pour
raconter ce qui se passe et voilà ils
ont du mal des fois les politiques à
penser que c'est pas parce qu'on est
sympa qu'on discute ce don va pas
raconter ce qui se passe derrière après
chaque journée il souhaite ce qu'il veut
mais enfin la déontologie est
normalement le métier c'est raconter ce
qui se passe pas le plan comme si fini
et tu veux rebondir je te pourtant des
doutes question non pas juste pour
rebondir c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
ça c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas besoin
andy méchant mais il ya en fait on n'est
pas forcément méchant pas du tout mais
juste on pose on pose des questions et
là si on pose certaines questions on est
méchant alors qu'on cherche juste à être
être factuel google
je gagne en ce moment pas grand chose
parce que je suis dévolu à notre projet
donc j'ai pas voilà je publie pas grand
chose mais sinon c'est entre 2000 et
2500 euros mais pas moi
je dirais plutôt brut mais ça peut être
n'êtes jeu fiscal de combien
j'en sais même rien puisque je suis
marié je me suis même plus aller à nice
mais la niche fiscale pardon ses 7500
euros
qu'on déduit des impôts mais qu'on
déduit de ce qu'on gagne donc en fait ça
fait ch et plus il y avait quelqu'un qui
l'avait calculé ça alors toi tu étais
pas d'accord ce que tu l'avais fait et
avait dit qu'on gagne et quand même ça
faisait une ristourne oui oui oui mais
pour revenir sur niches fiscales c'est
intéressant parce que ça aussi les gens
pour des questions disant pourquoi une
journée ils sont une niche fiscale c'est
coup les jo alors oui on voit le voit le
citoyen des citoyens sont pas les
journalistes et les citoyens qui se
posent des questions disant pourquoi
niches fiscales pour les journalistes
international à titre personnel si ça
pose problème moi je suis pour qu'on a
supprimé voilà après pourrait au départ
elles étaient faites pour parce que les
journées sont des frais qui n'étaient
pas remboursés par les rédactions
aujourd'hui les sols qui n'ont qui ont
des frais qui ne sont pas remboursés par
la rédaction cd pigiste sert les
journalistes indépendants les autres
quand ils vont manger au resto avec une
source ou apolitiques et tout ça il
présente la facture et c'est le journal
ou la télé qu'ils remboursent ce qui est
normal c'est après professionnels nous
j'allais dire pendant les sujets qu'on
fait on peut passer un certain nombre de
frais de moins en moins mais elle a
heureusement on ne rembourse quand même
en général tout une grosse partie de nos
frais professionnels peut toujours pas
toujours pas s'il ya des journaux qui
ont plus d'argent et donc il donc y i
mais god pour une nuit d'hôtel il met
got pour un repas revoilà mais pour
savoir que pour faire des sujets ou pour
des enquêtes qui durent longtemps
monsieur nous on présente le sujet quand
on est journaliste indépendant une fois
qu'on est sûr qu'on pourra le faire donc
c'est à dire par exemple toute la phase
de préparation d'une enquête pour être
sûr qu'on va arriver à quelque chose à
un sujet qu'on pourra vendre un journal
eh ben ça ça ne coûte des sous et leur
là il n'y a pas de rétroactivité et donc
nous mais clairement quand j'invite si
j'avais eu quelques au restaurant la
plupart du temps chez personnes qui
meurent avance mais ferait s'il faut que
je me déplace c'est pour moi donc denses
qui pour ce qui concerne les
journalistes indépendants
cette niche fiscale vient réellement
faire son travail c'est à dire que parce
que réellement j'ai des frais qui sont
pas remboursés après moi je comprends
que pour des journalistes en poste
c'est clairement une niche fiscale c'est
à dire un avantage
on pour payer moins d'impôts voilà qui
est pas forcément logique où tout de
suite fait sur les niches fiscales
exactement comme comme jacques en fait
je fais d'accord bon après voilà on se
focalise souvent sur cette histoire de
niches fiscales des journalistes mais
des niches fiscales il y en a des
milliers et des milliers les fabricants
de pipes de je ne sais pas où
saint-georges pas quoi ont aussi niches
fiscales fabrique des pipes bon
voilà en tant qu'indépendant moi j'ai
enfin il me semble qu'elle n'est pas
complètement à l'est pas complètement
quoi
c'est depuis pas indépendant qui
tablaient hors saison qui font qu aucune
mais je trouve quand en tant
qu'indépendant voilà sept niches
fiscales ne me choque pas plus que ça
parce qu'effectivement ça nous permet
quand même de garder cette indépendance
non
on va fermer sujet de la niche fiscale
j'ai une question à vous poser la ligue
du lol c'est quoi c'est comment vous
avez perçu ça commence à créer des
séquelles sur votre profession c'est
c'est
déjà ce écologique du même franchement
basse et un groupe de jeunes
journalistes
spécialisés dans les trucs de du web qui
voilà qu'il y avait des postes assez
élevé dans les rédactions
et qui avait créé un groupe sur facebook
eux puissent échanger les bons plans les
machins les jobs etc et puis ça a un peu
dérivé s'est sérieusement même en truck
de harcèlement contre
principalement des femmes souvent en
dise haut et des hommes souvent
précaires voilà et enfin franchement je
crois que faut pas le voir autrement que
comme un groupe de petits cons comme il
y en a dans toutes les professions c'est
à dire voilà des gens qui ont pété un
câble qui ont pris le melon et qui sont
mis à être agressif et désagréable avec
avec les autres enfin en trouve partout
des gens comme stéphanie vous connaissez
un peu la rédaction les tours d'ivoire
de certaines certains jours nous il y a
un phénomène de meute
parce que la ligue du lol c'est
peut-être simplement la face visible de
l'iceberg moi je sais pas là pour le
coup j'ai j'avais bien du mal à
comprendre même comment cela avait été
possible finalement cette clique du lot
donc non franchement je alors je suis
peut-être naïve mais je trouve ça juste
fou quoi vraiment justes et des
étudiants et après quand ils se
retrouvent en poste bizarrement il se
retrouve à des postes élevés et là ils
vont créer un truc et continuer comme à
la récréation à l'école mais là pour le
coup sur internet sur les réseaux
sociaux non moi j'ai quand même vraiment
du mal à comprendre finalement qu'on en
soit arrivé là franchement moi part
condamné parce que moi je connais ses
plages aucun journaliste qui était là
dedans voix j'ai peu été aux rédactions
mais dans les rédactions où j'étais on
n'était absolument pas concernée par ce
genre de phénomène voir en local
ouest-france et voilà donc et sinon
comme indépendant en fait on est éloigné
des décembre de pouvoir et voilà donc en
fait
bon j'ai trouvé sacrément hallucinant
enfin que ce soit possible et puis ça a
cassé des gens enfin je veux dire
humainement ça a cassé des gens c'est
quand même assez dramatique et c'est
bien qu'ils soient sanctionnés mais à
part ça j'ai pas de je sais pas je peux
pas expliquer pourquoi ils sont faits
qui sont ces gens là après ça pose aussi
une question qui est pas une
intéressante c'est que ces gens-là sont
ont été
catapultés
étiqueté grand spécialiste d'internet et
du web et de tout ça dans les rédactions
sur la base d'un truc tout simple c'est
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de followers
alors est ce que le fait d'être connu
sur les réseaux sociaux fait de toi un
expert du sujet internet je ne crois pas
maintenant ça pose vraiment une question
c'est comment des dirigeants de journaux
peuvent embaucher des gens en se disant
voilà un spécialiste d'internet pour
mettre dans ma rédaction
en se basant uniquement sur le nombre de
followers je me pose des questions sur
les capacités de management en fait des
dirigeants des rédactions qui ont fait
ces embauches
pour maintenant qu'on a fait les
présentations
vous êtes sur un documentaire
d'investigation
qui touche si je résume trivialement
environ 2 milliards de milliards de de
pauw you can use dingue si tu veux
montrer ton petit chien tu peux pas
le micro au plat
voilà on est bon ouais en coûte à pognon
dingue c'est bien connu est d'accord
donc je suis père mais détaille les
[Rires]
savants d'embêter des gens
qu'on espère un on est c'est fait ça
pourquoi pour l'intérêt général pour
voter clairement c'est clairement un
sujet d'intérêt général phase i way car
moi un sujet d'intérêt général alors moi
je dirais pas que je cherche
spécialement emmerder des gens pour le
coup mais je cherche absolument
effectivement à un mètre à un mètre de
la lumière sur des sujets qui reste
sinon cacher c'est vraiment pour ça je
pense qu'on fait ce travail là c'est que
l'investisseur journalisme
d'investigation sans lui il y a des
choses qui restent vraiment enterré
vraiment cacher on comprend pas
forcément voilà on a une communication
officielle
voilà c'est ce que disait jacques tout à
l'heure les conférences de presse en
fait c'est pour relayer la communication
officielle j'ai rien contre parce que
parfois il ya là il ya un nouveau une
nouvelle politique qui veut nouvelles
mesures bon bah il faut bien qu'on nous
la présente avant éventuellement de se
poser des questions et se demandent est
ce qu il en est donc jeudi rapporté que
le gouvernement va proposer telle ou
telle loi ça me paraît en même temps
tout à fait honnête comme le travail
face à me pose pas de problème c'est
qu'on a la chance de musique la charte
de munich
[Musique]
1910 18la probyn oui mais je veux dire
un machin qui tous oui non mais moi
c'est complètement dépassés ce truc là
tout pourquoi pas c'est complètement
dépassés puisque en gros si tu veux on
te dit pour obtenir des informations
tu ne dois pas utiliser des moyens
déloyaux mais le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui en face de nous on a des
multinationales avec des budgets comme
des avocats qui ont des milliards
dépensés pour écraser une info qui les
dérangent eux ont des moyens qui sont
largement déloyaux quant à des officines
qui viennent voilà où des services de
renseignement qui viennent piquer des
ordinateurs dans des rédactions je suis
désolé les moyens déloyaux ils sont pas
chez nous donc bref tu prêches pour
équilibrer il passait lambeaux de bain
on sent tout cas être un petit peu plus
offensif et pas forcément voilà enfin je
sais il s'agit pas d'aller voler des
informations ce parce que je n'y mets
j'ai craint si on ne peut pas ben
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais c'est sûr
que tu situe si tu es invité pour
visiter un ehpad et qu'on te fait faire
le tour de l'ehpad tout va être propre
trouve être joli si tu viens en caméra
cachée ça va pas être pareil donc oui
bien sûr stephen dix
mois le plus possible jeu j'essaye
d'être le plus honnête possible mais
effectivement je veux dire honnête dans
le sens où je vais dire pourquoi je suis
là etc mais je suis assez d'accord avec
mes petits camarades c'est à dire que on
se rend bien compte que six
annonce directement ce pourquoi on est
là on aura malheureusement très peu de
résultats mais toute façon tu vois bien
quand tu appelles aujourd'hui c'est un
truc assez fascinant tu appelles un
ministère et tu leur dis voilà bonjour
vous êtes le service de presse j'ai
besoin de telles informations réponse
envoyez nous un mail
d'envoi un mail et puis après tu appuies
jamais de réponse et tu passes des mois
comme ça à relancer des services de
presse dont le métier est de répondre
aux journalistes air qui sont payés pour
répondre aux journalistes et en fait il
ne répond pas total essayé un peu le
quai d'orsay le porte parole du quai
d'orsay le quai d'orsay je sais plus
mais j'ai le ministère de la défense
j'ai fait plusieurs fois ces noms c'est
marrant aurait effectivement il se passe
rien donc
on les interpelle même maintenant sur
twitter mais ça bouge pas ils disent
vous on va vous répondre parce que t'as
pas assez de fond noir oui ça doit être
ça quand tu démarres québec trois cent
mille chômeurs d'après les gendarmes ça
doit être ça mais c'est sûr que oui je
pense qu'il ya des oui il ya des quand
même des journalistes qui réussissent à
avoir des informations mais c'est drôle
c'est la télé finalement qu'il réussit
encore à avoir des d un faux pas des
réponses je veux dire je sais pas si
c'est des infos en tout cas des réponses
je pense qu'aujourd'hui par exemple ya
des sujets en dehors de la filtration
est nécessaire on le voit aujourd'hui
pour plein de sujets j'ai à dire c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de ne pas avancer
forcément toujours comme journaliste on
le voit moi par exemple je connais une
personne en arn qui a fait un livre dans
la peau du jihadiste où elle s'est fait
passer pour une convertie qui voulaient
rejoindre deich en syrie bien évidemment
qu'elle s'est fait un faux profil elle
s'est fait voilà une légende de
convertis et ça lui a permis de
dialoguer avec des djihadistes en syrie
et de sortir un livre qu'à être caf un
carton et ça n'aurait pas pu le faire si
elle dit bonjour je suis bidule et lui
livre le livre il s'appelle dans la peau
de nos jihadistes là il vient de sortir
en poche voilà donc sa faim voilà ça
fait un carton moi je travaille sur un
autre sujet non on en train de faire
aussi on objet de faire d'infiltration
voilà donc de te faire des grandes
icônes ou de faire des caméras cachées
maintenant parce que on prend un pseudo
en prime ce dos et voilà et si donc on
est obligé de faire ça ou d'aller faire
des caméras cachées pour dans le cadre
de documentaires télé souvent donc j'ai
de le faire un moment j'avais une
question parce que je laisse un petit
peu vous avez fait des caméras cachées
pour votre documentaire qui va sortir
sur internet d'ailleurs vous avez un
site de crowdfunding
alors ne donnait pas tout seul alors non
donc on sait pas s'il y aura besoin de
caméras cachées si on peut éviter on
évitera mais s'il faut aussi on y arrive
on le fera voilà ils ont joué voilà un
site le site du conte alors le style de
kung fu ying nous commander une
association de les 900 on est sur hello
aso et donc il y a il ya un
impossibilité de ton sur l oiseau et ses
ailes loi c'est bit.ly on a fait 1 on a
fait un lien cours bit.ly slash reflet
au pluriel tv voilà ça c'est trop
compliqué
hot one way et non pour les caméras
cachées je reviens juste sur un truc par
exemple voilà je suis je suis allé à
milipol lorenzo voilà bon je me pointe
si des vidéos ouais on les avait
publiées jeux sortis sur mes épaules
c'est le salon sur lequel viennent tous
les ans fin les services de police
renseignements militaires a dit à pour
s'équiper ces deux supermarchés en fait
d'eux des services de des forces de
l'ordre et services de renseignement
farfouille ou à la foir'fouille idées et
donc tu peux acheter un m6 catcheur un
truc blindés d'ici catcheur qui permet
d'intercepter des communications des gsm
et avoir brillé à dia de tous et donc je
suis allé sur le stand d'amesys sur
lequel gaëtan écrit machin bonjour je
vais rencontrer le patron
et là j'ai pas le temps de de dire quoi
que ce soit il ya un type et à monsieur
champagne non non vous répondra pas
messi mais il est là le patron non non
on vous répondra pas voilà et puis il ya
quelqu'un d'autre qui est venu après
avec une caméra cachée et ils y ont
déballé tout le tout programme tout ce
qui faisait comment ils pouvaient
intercepté toutes les communications sur
internet c est tous leurs clients voilà
donc pas dit qu'il était journaliste
donc voilà donc parfois tu es un peu
obligé parce que sinon on te dit rien
que d'autres quoi d'autre quoi d'autre
on peut parler un peu de quelques
enquêtes si ça intéresse
les dessous des enquêtes tudou demandait
nos faits d'armes il ya pour dire la
complexité par exemple j'enquête sur 1
c'est un des plus gros scandales
financiers de la planète s'appelle one m
diby les gens connaissent pas trop c'est
un fonds souverain malaisien qui a été
pillé ils ont volé 8 à 10 milliards de
dollars 8 à 10 milliards de dollars donc
l'argent de ces petites bières et que ça
ouais ouais ben il est possible qu'une
partie de l'argent et soit partie en
libye on nous a dit ça en libye en syrie
mais on a axé sa s'est servi à acheter
des armes mais bon ça on n'a pas un sens
on l'a prouvé mais donc un jour on a une
source qui nous dit il ya une partie de
l'argent qui est caché en france et donc
on nous donne les noms de mec donc on
commence à regarder effectivement ils
ont des sociétés ils ont acheté plein de
bien sur la côte d'azur à saint-trop'
immeuble à paris voilà donc on commence
à lyster veut tous les biens qu'ils ont
dans sa vers ça que la gare il y en a
vraiment pour du pognon et que les dates
d'achat correspondent au moment où ils
ont volé dans la caisse quoi donc bon et
blanquette et la durée c'est à dire pour
faire ça par exemple ça a été à peu près
neuf mois
pour établir un peu qui étaient ces mecs
qu'elles vont en plus celle des
connexions politiques en france on
savait pas si ça pourrait donner quelque
chose eh ben donc après à la fin je vais
voir le parquet national financier je le
redis pour savoir bonjour avec vous au
courant avait ouvert sur ce dossier
alors ce dossier un peu connue parce que
il ya eu aussi beaucoup d'argent qui est
parti aux états unis puisqu'elle rigueur
oui pardon et quelques mois il ya eu
deux morts un banquier assassiné et la
lame et trace du premier ministre qui a
été retrouvé dispersés façon puzelat
l'explosif voit la bbc bien non d'un
collier miss malaisie en commun les ils
vendent assez d'argent malaisie way
criante chute ouais voilà et donc
donc je vois le parc national financier
je leur dis bah est ce que vous
connaissez dossier vous avez ouvert et
tout petit lien non non je suis pas au
courant et regard dit non à pau vers
minuit par contre votre article
m'intéresse et donc on a publié là le
premier dans marianne et suite à ça ils
ont ouvert une information judiciaire et
actuellement je sais qu'ils ont saisi
plus de 100 millions d'euros
donc qui a été de l'argent que les mecs
ont piqué dans la caisse
8 à 10 milliards oui bah c'est non mais
c'est une petite partie la france c'est
une goutte d'eau mais les mecs après ils
ont dispersé l'argent et c'est pas fini
si l'on dépiste maintenant sur l'ancien
premier ministre malaisien razak et qui
lui aussi a pas mal de biens en france
une autre petite histoire concerne ou
des rédactions qui vous court circuite
ou des choses comme ça vous
savez l'histoire âgées une belle
histoire libyenne alors les images les
histoires des biens ouais ça l'est pas
mal elle a donné lieu aussi une
ouverture op ed f on est partis au
départ c'étaient des merciers de suite
aussi voilà au départ c'était des
médecins qui râlaient parce qu'ils
avaient été virés de libye au moment de
la prise de la guerre par une société
française il disait derrière ça sent pas
bon et tout ça et c'est en fait il avait
alerté le service enquêtes du point le
magazine le point
ça c'est sûr si c'est ou bien ouais
c'est tout dit pas oui j'ai tout
bétonner et donc est donc le point moi
je les rencontre parce que je revenais
de libye ils disent là nous on n'a pas
le temps est ce que ça te dirait pas
travailler là dessus et si tu trouves tu
publies je dis ok et je me mets avec un
petit collègues du collectif parce que
les enquêtes
c'est tellement long et c'est tellement
une pelote de laine et c'est tellement
compliqué qu'on essaie souvent de se
mettre à deux pour pouvoir échanger pas
être seul face à son sujet être
complètement perdu et noyé dans son
sujet et ados on a plus de vide et on
discute on tire les pistes ensemble et
si hier on y arrive à rien gagné a varié
ensemble
et donc là on commence à attirer des
pelotes et tout et on s'aperçoit que
derrière il ya un marché de 30 millions
qui était confiée à une boîte sorti de
nulle part
et sur ordre direct de l'elysée de
sarkozy et ce marché d'équipement d'un
hôpital libyen était une des
contreparties de la libération des
infirmières bulgares 0 marchés publics
et la boîte le projet directement
pilotée par l'elysée et là on à l'ancien
consul
honoraire de france là-bas qui décide de
nous parler parce qu'il ait pris sa
retraite et donc il nous raconte les
dessous du marché a dit ouais c'était
comment mais au départ on m'a même
demandé à en créer une association loi
1901 pour récupérer les 30 millions
d'élise il dit mais moi je verrais
répondu je voulais pas finir en prison
et donc est donc c'est passé par l'
agence française de développement qui
d'habitude ne s'occupe pas de la libye
jeudi l'afd et l'afd a eu une dérogation
et à récupérer sur directement un budget
présidentiel de 30 millions qui a été
reversé à cette boîte est là et bien
servi de banque l'afd d'ailleurs m'a
parlé parce que et quand ils ont vu
aussi les emmerdes gens qui étaient là
dessus il ya des gens de rêver qui m'ont
qui m'ont dit attendez nous on veut bien
se dédouaner ils m'ont montré le
document ils vont passer le document
montrant que c'était un ordre signé
direct des ministres et tous parce qu'il
savait que ça c'est certain ah ouais
c'est sorti alors au départ ça devait
sortir dans le point donc voilà il y
avait donc c'était chaud parce que quand
même le consul de france l'avancé quand
même fait mitrailler dans sa bagnole
donc quoi parmi trahison pris 12 balles
de flingues avec sa femme heureusement
ils ont ils ont vraiment un miracle ils
n'ont pas été touchés il ya un français
qui est en charge de la sécurité de
l'hôpital qui était assassiné voilà donc
c'était quand même chaud et donc voilà
est donc ce qui sait ce qui s'est passé
à ce moment là c'est que nous on écrit
l'article
et là on va voir la boîte en question et
la boîte en question ils nous disent non
mais toute façon votre article il
sortirait pas parce que je connais un
administrateur du point
donc nous rigole quoi écouter désolé
mais non mais ça marche pas comme ça ça
va parce que vous connaissez un
administrateur du poids qu'on sent qu'on
sort pas un papier donc voilà on écrit
des enquêtes il l enquête elle est mise
en page prêtes à être publiées et là on
nous dit bah c'est décalé et finalement
nous dit que ça sortira pas ça va rester
sur les étagères donc là on était payé
ils ont payé des frais ils ont payé
l'enquêtre comme s'ils avaient été
publiés
et nous on dit c'est terminé et puis bon
le service enquêtes évidemment il
faisait la gueule le service enquête ils
nous ont dit d'aller voir ailleurs donc
huit jours plus tard on a une petite
enquête qui est sorti dans le canard
enchaîné
voilà et puis
encore quelques mois plus tard on a
sorti l'intégralité de l'enquète dans
une revue qui venait de sortir le numéro
d'une revue d'investigation qui
malheureusement n'existe plus qu'ils
s'appellent sang froid ça + wii qui
s'appelait sang froid bon il change de
formule ils feront plus d'investigations
voilà est donc là on sort l'intégralité
de l'enquète et là encore le parquet
national financier s'intéresse au
dossier il avait déjà la boîte dans le
collimateur et du coup il ouvre aussi là
dessus
et pour dire oui par rapport aux points
pour terminer c'est que nous on dit rien
quand on est pigiste en général on ferme
sa gueule parce que ça peut être un
client demain donc en général on dit
rien on a là on avale la couleuvre on se
tait on publier ailleurs ça c'est là
l'avantagé que nous on peut aller
ailleurs pour publier si on nous propose
un truc et là on ne dit rien jusqu'à ce
que mediapart raconte que le point a
censuré une autre enquête libyenne
concernant sarkozy est là le l'ats le
rédacteur en chef du point d'indicé fait
que new cerise insulte aux médias à
gernelle et donc il voilà donc ils
insultent mediapart en disant si
n'importe quoi c'est une technologie est
tout ça moi je suis un an nous on est
intègre et tous
et donc du coup j'ai contacté vaches
travaille aussi pour médiapart donc j'ai
contacté fabrice arfi qui gérait le
dossier est donc je vais dire à nous
aussi on a une bonne histoire est
racontée et on avait la lettre de la
boîte qui avait été envoyé un
administrateur du point qui connaissait
demandant que l'article ne paraissent
pas
et donc pour dire voilà pour durer c'est
ça qui est incroyable et donc ça arrive
évidemment que des journaux
c'est à dire sans sur 10 ans tout est
vouloir vous dire vous complétez amendé
c'est un beau british police bah ça
dépend comment tu le fais mais de toute
façon tu vois bien que il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui sont très évidente
est logique par exemple est ce que tu
penses que tu vas voir une enquête un
peu désagréable sur lvmh dans les échos
non appartient à lvmh bon tu peux faire
la même chose avec à peu près tous les
tous les journaux donc est il ya quand
même un problème quelque part avant les
journaux étaient détenus par des gens
dont le métier était de faire des
journaux maintenant ces détenus par des
industriels ça pose un vrai problème sa
phase i
bah c'est à dire que oui on est on s'en
rend compte de toute façon que on est
parfois bloqués il ya déjà des sujets on
se dit on va pas le proposer à untel on
va plutôt le proposer à un autre et le
fait qu'on soit indépendante nous permet
d'avoir cette liberté et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on veut qu'on veut lancer nos
documentaires d'investigation nous
allons
donc vous avez décidé de faire un peu
l'internet pour toutes ces raisons là
pour voir franchir 2 déjà il ya des
côtes télé qu'on a envie de casser on a
envie de casser certains codes télé
c'est bien pour certaines choses mais on
se dit qu'on peut faire un peu autrement
pour internet et puis d'autre part il ya
de moins en moins de casse
d'investigation la télé évidemment il ya
caché investigations il ya complément
d'enquêté il y en a quand même mais par
exemple où jaillit well as of c'est une
boîte de prod première ligne qui fait
caché investigations tout allait bien
sûr mais ils font du super boulot mais
la question c'est que malheureusement
ils font un sujet de temps en temps
voilà alors qu'il en aurait plein
d'autres affaires et c'est là qu'on se
dit qu'avec la liberté d'internet à
condition d'avoir des gens qui nous
soutiennent parce que pour l'instant
princes il ya un modèle économique est
quand même très fragile donc vous pouvez
pas là clairement on cherche 20000 euros
vingt mille euros on se paye pas dire
qu'on va payer les compétences qu'on n'a
pas en interne au collectif c'est à dire
on va payer le monteur parce que ça on
n'a pas la personne qui fera de
l'infographie parce qu'il faut beaucoup
d'infographie pour expliquer des choses
compliquées et ça ça coûte cher voilà tu
les fais cuire les frais des frais de
déplacement et puis on provisionnent
déjà quelques milliers d'euros pour
l'avocat parce que on sait on sait qu'on
aura déjà une procédure des diffamations
procédure bâillon oui bien sûr mais
c'est à dire c'est un classique la rance
à dire quand wall e le crowdfunding de
journalistes sur internet
c'est en train d'émerger c'est en train
de se renforcer ça fonctionne pas
ça fonctionne c'est moyennement je
dirais encore en france
ceci dit tu vois bien que il ya un
des trucs c'est vrai mais c'est le truc
cyclique on a déjà eu dans les années
2000 un mouvement des dix journalistes
citoyens c'est en fait voilà internet
permet à chacun de devenir un émetteur
un journaliste donc il ya eu dans les
années 2000 un mouvement comme ça
notamment aux états unis tous les trucs
les manifestations contre la faim
pendant la période bush donc oui il ya
déjà eu ça aujourd'hui ça revient un
petit peu tu vois que les gilet jaune
essaye voilà d'avoir leurs propres
canaux
de diffusion d'information dont il ya
des gens qui effectivement demande aux
internautes de financer des enquêtes
mais c'est aussi parce que nous pourquoi
on fait ça c'est parce que tu te rends
compte que tu as
ddd code des a priori dans la profession
qui font que par exemple on va te dire
là typiquement le sujet qu'on veut
aborder marchés publics argent voilà on
va te dire mais comment tu vas le mettre
en image ça va être compliqué
c'est pas visuel c'est pas bon voilà en
fait en gros on me dit non ça marche
aussi pour certaines enquêtes on va dire
non ça c'est passé conso s'est passé je
sais pas quoi du coup bon là c'est
concernant voilà pas la sortie s'est
passé concernant ça c'est le seul qui
dit ça le truc de la télé qu'est ce qui
dit ça c'est en fait on n'a pas
forcément accès aux chaînes directement
ses les boîtes de prod qui travaillent
qui ensuite propose les sujets aux
chaînes donc mais on sait pas vraiment
s'il ya vraiment une politique derrière
s'il ya vraiment quelqu'un qui dit ça on
veut pas ça en veut ça on n'en sait rien
nous on est juste à un niveau ou sur
l'investigation comme c'est difficile de
le mettre en image souvent on nous dit
c'est pas assez concernant tu peux pas
nous parler plutôt d'un truc donc entre
guillemets + conso c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir aujourd'hui s'il ya une vraie
tyrannie de l'audience c'est que les
chaînes de télé les grandes chaînes de
télé suivre l'audience d'une émission
minute par minute et c'est à partir de
là qu'ils calment c'est à partir de là
qui calme les sujets suivants et donc en
fait ils disent si ça a bien marché avec
ça il faut que je reprenne des trucs
comme ça plus tard donc les rédacteurs
en chef aussi ont la pression de
l'audience même des rédactions et
rédacteur en chef qui sont des vrais
journalistes et qui est des fois ils
trouvent le sujet super mais disent mais
ça va pas être assez concernant pour les
jeunes hôtes ce qu'ils voient c'est
vraiment l'audience minute par minute et
voilà ils suivent ça et donc ils volent
des trucs entre guillemets qui marche et
ça c'est une tyrannie de l'audience qui
marchent parce qu'il est de plus bien
ouais bien sûr derrière il ya derrière
ces questions de pub pareil enfin tu
prends ce l'interview personnes offre
est ce à dire on va [__] de une deux
personnes sur un fond noir trois
aujourd'hui voilà et puis on va parler
pendant une heure et demie voilà vous
fait une super audience personne ne
ferais ça aujourd'hui en télé j'ai à
dire c'est pas il n'y a pas de place
pour ça il ya eu un petit peu il ya
longtemps où il y avait des choses un
peu comme ça pas formaté qui ont amené
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est dans des
choses très formaté voilà bah il ya un
programme à tenir ceci dit enfin je veux
dire internet nous permet justement
cette liberté c'est ça qui nous on s'est
dit on n'a qu'à essayer essayons
essayons sur internet et voyons si ça si
ça fonctionne ou pas c'est finalement on
fait un match plein on fait quoi on
recommence à ottawa j'espère que ça va
fonctionner tout cas retourner tout cas
derrière vous sera posée sur des
vecteurs de communication pour toi si tu
devais
taclé un sujet
comme ça ton un sujet d'investigation tu
choisirais comme priorité
la bouffe le fric ou sexe la politique
la drogue
finances publiques franchement je sais
pas c'est des trucs qui viennent loubic
ouais alors beau de toute façon génocide
oui bon pourquoi pas un an mais ce que
j'ai beaucoup fait surveillance de masse
et je n'ai pas posé toujours toujours
avec il ya toujours un prisme de mes
débuts j'en aï ci qui font que je pense
que
derrière toute chose un peu importante
qu'il ya toujours des histoires de gros
sous en fait donc ça reste lié à
l'économie et à la finance etc
voilà derrière il se passe quelque chose
donc c'est des trucs qu'on peut creuser
de soi sont des sujets ils viennent un
peu comme ça par hasard parce que voilà
il ya quelqu'un qui te quitte alerte sur
quelque chose que toi dans ton dans ton
milieu dans ton cercle tu ne vois pas
lui la vue parce que c'est son truc à
lui d'en parler puis après tu vas comme
disait jacques tu déroule un peu la
pelote et tu trouves tu trouve des trucs
à ce qu'on avait fait sur le bardo par
exemple
avec jacques on avait travaillé sur
l'attentât du bardo en tunisie ben on
s'est rendu compte que le juge français
avait une toute petite partie du dossier
d'instruction
tunisiens que ce dossier d'instruction
tunisien s'était absolument n'importe
quoi c'était un truc de malade on a
épluché un nombre de documents mais
monumental parce qu'on avait le dossier
de ces d'instruction à tel point
d'ailleurs que au début on pense à
prendre des notes sur des cahiers puis
on saigne et on m'a jamais s'y retrouver
donc c'est là on a fait rentrer
un logiciel que voilà que tu te
connaître s'appelle maltais go qui
permet de recréer une scène de crime
avec des entités dessus faire des liens
entre les gens liés des documents à
chaque entité qui a mis sur ton écran et
donc au bout d'un moment tu fini par
voir apparaître en fait des bulles de
gens qui sont en lien les uns avec les
autres alors que
on en parle un peu au début du dossier
et puis après un peu milieu puis à peu
après après la fin mais toi en fait sur
ton écran tu vois apparaître des bulles
de gens qui sont ensemble c'est
intéressant mais
ce qui était bizarre dans cette histoire
du bardo c'est que des gens qui étaient
très très proche des terroristes voire
complice doit d'ailleurs aussi qui avait
été présenté comme le chef de cellule
terroriste avait été libéré voilà donc
on a refait un peu de cette
contre-enquête voilà un parent qui par
les tunisiens par des tunisiens en
disant alors certains avaient été
libérés parce que il avait plaidé que
leurs aveux avaient été obtenus sous la
torture donc on avait des expertises
médicales alors pour certains c'était
compatible pour d'autres pas trop voit
là est la question mais la question la
question de leur culpabilité se posait
toujours par exemple il y avait un des
types qui avait été libérée il avait fui
en libye pour rejoindre à un groupe
islamiste
voilà donc ce qui prouve qu'il était
quand même enfin dans la mouvance et
peut-être est probablement liée plus ou
moins l'attentât
donc c'est intéressant on a refait cette
enquête avec
l'aide aussi de sources en tunisie dont
certaines ont été arrêtés des policiers
qui avaient dénoncé des choses qui ont
été arrêtés et mis en prison au moins
pour l'un d'entre eux voilà donc
c'est vrai que les les enquêtes ce qui
est intéressant ce qu'il dit antoine
c'est que
ça il ya plusieurs choses il ya les
sources humaines mais il ya aussi
énormément de documents et là il faut de
l'aide pour gérer ses documents et là
encore ça coûte cher parce que par
exemple il dit on a utilisé malte ego
mal tes gosses est décédé logiciel il
faut s'abonner
chaque année il faut payer pour des
options
par exemple quand on fait des recherches
internet des enquêtes sur des gens qu'on
va aller voir des choses qui ne sont pas
indexés par google
il faut payer des logiciels voilà et ça
ça fait partie et fred enquête
aujourd'hui même les rédactions n'en
sont pas là on n'a même pas d'être des
rédactions c'est à dire que nous ils
attendent qu'on amène des choses mais
eux-mêmes même s'ils ont les moyens ils
connaissent pas tout ça et il nous aide
pas du tout évidente pour réserver des
documents va retrouver les siens qui
comprennent rien quand tu leur parles de
matteo et comprennent pas bon mais ça
c'est pas très étonnant ceci dit non non
c'est pas étonnant mais voilà c'est des
trucs qui sont de type de logiciel de
procréer une scène de crime c'est celui
qui sont utilisés par les flics voilà on
sait pas c'est pas complètement
également un problème de l'enquète cette
façon c'est que ça prend énormément de
temps donc toute façon même si on
n'utilise pas du logiciel même si etc ça
prend énormément de temps et d'avoir les
documents non mais de récupérer les
documents des documents qui sont
communicables normalement à toute
personne qui en fait la demande je veux
dire on n'arrive pas à les avoir parce
et pourtant nés en france donc il faut
passer par une commission qui est
spécialisé là dedans pour avoir des
documents qui normalement devrait nous
être fournie dès qu'on en fait la
demande qu'on soit journalistes ou
simples c'est loupé rien pas celle c'est
vraiment c'est on n'y arrive pas c'est
l'omerta c'est là le manque de
transparence en france du coup on attend
donc la vie qui est seulement
consultatif de cette commission est
ensuite maintenant ça ne suffit même
plus donc il faut aller au tribunal
administratif etc ce cas donc c'est des
procédures très longues agences ou co2
dissous qui font obstruction mais non
plus d'un an ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'on voit qu'il ya une opacité qui est
organisée c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'il ya une opacité qui organisait par
notre propre administration
et ça c'est un vrai problème on parle d'
open data mais quand on demande les
documents nous les donne pas voilà et on
est parti pour deux ans de procédure le
dernier exemple c'était parodie de
natation comme la conquête très
concrètement on devait aller au tribunal
administratif enfin je devais aller au
tribunal admistratif l'année semaine
dernière et je n'y suis pas allé parce
que manger on a remis quelque chose en
cours mais le début de l'action c'est
janvier 2017 je demande de plusieurs
marchés publics et des statistiques des
statistiques concernant les fameux
radars automatiques en caoutchouc voilà
je les ai pas je saisis donc cette
fameuse commission et qui rêve qui donne
un avis en gros favorable puis le
ministère de l'intérieur ne donne
toujours pas suit donc je saisi le
tribunal administratif à l'été 2010 est
on est en avril 2019 j'attends la
première audience devant le tribunal
administratif
c'est organisé six ou simplement de la
lenteur administrative non non j'ai
organisé
du mais non mais ces individus atteints
c'est pas c'est pas une stratégie
organisée décidé au niveau c'est
simplement que les gens pensent que ils
sont pas se justifier en fait ils n'ont
pas à te donner les infos que tu
demandes c'est exactement ce qu'on me
disait tout à l'heure sur tu appelles un
service de presse dont le métier est de
communiquer des informations aux
journalistes qui leur demandent des
trucs et ils te disent on va vous
répondre et à ton pendant des mois c'est
surréaliste honnêtement quand j'allais
dire ce qui est incroyable c'est quand
même on a des fonctionnaires qui ne
respectent pas la loi il encaisse qu'il
a causé à oui biensur qui la connaît
c'est pour ça que moi je suis moi je
fais le géant
aurait bien sûr on leur dit ouais c'est
à fait partie des pièces qui partent
d'après la loi qui doivent pouvoir être
communiquée sous certaines conditions et
une fois qu'on le rappelle sa il les
donne pas et il s'en fout et donc le
principe nous on est on est pris dans le
tape le mur d'un ben voilà bon bah c'est
simple ils répondent pour y répondre par
envoi des mails ils répondent pas donc
au bout d'un certain temps on voit faut
saisir la cada lacadin qu'un avis
consultatif et après une fois que la vie
est donné il est favorable mais ils ne
font toujours pas alors que là on
pourrait dire il s'exécuterait et le
candide d'accord c'est quoi c'est une
administration soviétique où ils font ça
limiterait despatie c'est quoi moi je
pense qu'ils craignent les ennuis il dit
si un journaliste qui le demandent je
donne mon patron me châtain à laurence
away il ya un peu de ça et puis
qu'est-ce qui va trouver qu'est ce
qu'ils cherchent
et donc du coup ils ne respectent pas la
loi il préfère en disant bas on va
attendre c'est en principe de précaution
tu vois oui presque quoi c'est ça
principe de précaution pas dans merde
ils ont un certain pouvoir le pouvoir de
ne pas donner les documents qui sont
normalement communicables à toute
personne qui en font la demande et
lafarge leur façon astérix est à dire qu
il trouve au service
maintenant parce que dans l'est dans le
cadre de cette loi ou normalement un
document administratif qui est
communicable donc à toutes personnes ont
fait la demande de toute façon il suffit
juste de s'adresser à la bonne
administration ensuite même si on s'est
pas adressé aux bons services dans cette
administration la loi veut que de toute
façon le service qui a reçu la demande
va donc transféré aux bons services donc
de toute façon c'est pas un problème ont
saisi l'administration qui selon nous à
le document est celle ci ne répond pas
mais moi je pense que c'est pas
tellement les fonctionnaires qui veulent
pas c'est quand même ceux qui sont
finalement qui sait les politiques 1
c'est ceux qui sont nommés à des postes
stratégiques par les politiques ou les
ministres même enfin qui disent non ça
on communique martyrs que les
fonctionnaires ne sont pas indépendantes
du pouvoir politique
sont décodés bon question d'internet
vous choisissez qu'est ce qu'ils y
répondent est-ce que vous avez vu un
changement depuis la loi sur le secret
des affaires j'allais venir justement
enfin je sais pas si c'est tellement la
loi pour être tout à fait honnête et
sincère je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
loi des secrets des affaires mais il ya
une évolution par rapport à ces
documents administratifs il fut un temps
je demandais les marchés publics je
n'avais pas non plus donc je saisisse et
au lycée la cada mais parmi les
documents de ces marchés publics je
pouvais avoir accès à ce qu'on appelle
les bordereaux de prix unitaire les bpe
donc ça nous permet en fait la ministre
tient à un marché public un appel
d'offres un contrat donc avant avant de
signer un contrat avec une entreprise
l'état en gros il va il va dire il va
rédiger un appel d'offres il va dire
j'ai besoin d'eux si j'ai besoin de ça
et c il va y avoir un fichier excel avec
telle prestation je voudrais que vous me
fassiez telle prestation alors parlons
d'un truc que je connais très bien par
exemple et radar alors il faut et la
fourniture de radars ensuite il faut le
poser le radar l'installer enfin voilà
donc c'est combien coûte le radar
combien coûte le fait qu'on va le poser
quelque part voilà donc à chaque fois il
ya une ligne de prix mais quatre sont
super efficace qui vous du marquoir il
paraît donc il se trouve que on avait le
détail de ces prix là on n'avait pas le
pourquoi ça coûtait vraiment ce prix là
mais on avait au moins prestations par
prestation le détail de ces prix est
bien aujourd'hui
on n'y a plus accès ya une jurisprudence
qui fait qu'on n'a plus accès au
bordeaux on a le prix global mais
ensuite on n'a pas le détail prestations
par prestation dans le marché avec le
radar est notifié fait graisser la patte
ouais
par exemple deux manches alors sur le
secret des affaires là avec un collègue
du collectif on a sorti une affaire sur
une biotech qui a cramé plus 100
millions dans des projets complètement
foireux à base de microalgues voilà qui
marchait pas eh ben
c'est sorti juste avant c'est sorti
juste avant la loi secret des affaires
est en cours de discussion et le pdg
nous a dit aïe c'est dommage ainsi avec
la loi secret des affaires et ben comme
ça on aurait pu vous attaquez bon il
aura pu attaquer en diffamation ils
n'ont pas fait voilà on avait tous voila
mais parce que comme on utilisait des
documents de la boîte et qui savait
qu'on avait accès à ces documents eh
bien ils auraient pu nous attaquer parce
qu'on avait utilisé des documents qu'ils
auraient fait qu'ouvrir passe évidemment
par saccades et à faire oublier sur
internet est ce que vous craignez d'un
jury
judiciarisation de votre métier
bah oui et déjà déjà on a des procédures
bâillon diffamation régulièrement voilà
non mais on retombe dans ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'en face
de nous on a des gens qui ont des
budgets
pour les pour les procès qui sont
limités par rapport à ça que vous
demandez à l'aide pour un internet pour
être plus fortes communautés vous
renforcez évidemment plus on est de
monde et plus il ya de gens qui sont à
nos côtés pour jeu confiant et voilà est
qui qui sont intéressés par nos sujets
sains plus on sent fort et ça c'est
clair c'est clair que journaliste
d'investigation c'est essentiel pour la
démocratie
je crois que ça l'a montré sinon on
aurait peut-être sans doute eu fillon
comme président on n'a rien su de la
ferme et nahla il ya tellement
d'affaires qu'on n'aurait pas su les
wikileaks y avait pas eu d'après des
journalistes pour s'emparer de toute
cette masse de données alors là d'un
bail c'est
wikileaks c'est bien ce qui se fait
serrer qui se fait passer l'équateur qui
touche le jour besson compliqué on
connaît vient de s'écouler
mais en termes de journalisme
certes c'est un mauvais signal mais
c'est un mauvais signal qui se renforce
mais qui existe déjà depuis longtemps
enfin je viens depuis bush depuis le 11
septembre tu as un certain nombre de
guerres qui ont été déclenchées qui sont
totalement injustifiable où il s'est
passé absolument n'importe quoi ou c'est
censé être la première démocratie du
monde qui s'est mise à torturer des gens
enlevaient des gens
déposer des gens dans des prisons pour
qu'ils soient torturés des plus grands
d'europe en europe et dans des pays et à
transporter 80 et persanes associe aussi
à transporter ce qu'ils appellent des du
sur d'autres se passait rien bien sûr
pour les ont bien sûr tu as eu quand
même un truc comme guantanamo qui en
fait une prison dans laquelle tu es
enfermé hors système judiciaire sans
perspective de procès enfin c'est un
truc de dingue quant à une démocratie
qui dérivent complètement tu as
énormément de journalistes et notamment
wikileaks avec collatéral murder qui en
fait une vidéo prises depuis un
hélicoptère américain où il tire comme
des dingos sur des sites simoni aidez à
l'époque sur des sur des civils et des
journalistes bon tu as partir de là si
tu veux se met en place une volonté de
faire taire les gens qui contestent la
vérité officielle la vérité officielle
étant on attaque l'irak et en attaque
talent ganis temps parce que c'est ben
laden qui a fait tomber les tours bon on
voit pas ce que l'irak vient faire dans
l'histoire personne ne comprend mais il
y a une espèce d'histoire qui racontait
comme ça qu'ils passent d'ailleurs la
presse américaine tu as deux
journalistes qui dans leur coin font des
enquêtes de malades explique que tout ça
est un montage complet que y'a rien de
vrai dans cette histoire ils sont pas
écoutés ils sont pas publiées sont
taillés ils se font un peu taillé voilà
bon et donc en gros tu as une politique
gouvernementale américaine qui se met en
place pour faire taire les lanceurs
d'alert et faire taire en leur faisant
suffisamment peur enfin puisque bob
bradley manning à l'époque donc
aujourd'hui chelsa chelsea se prend 35
ans de prison trente cinq ans de prison
aberrant pour avoir communiqué des
informations qui ne sont pas fausses qui
sont vrais sur ce que fait l'armée a
mélangé de sécurité d'un guide pas du
tout est aveugle quand tu fais tes
petites affaires l'étrange les six
candidats aura des gens ouais bon donc
donc voila et évidemment on va
poursuivre aussi les journalistes ou les
gens qui font office de journalistes
comme
wikileaks prend peu discuté beaucoup sur
wikileaks on sera sage il ya des choses
à dire
c'est ni tout blanc ni tout noir comme
tout voilà mes mais il ya une vraie
volonté de faire taire ces gens là et ça
a continué après sous obama les lanceurs
d'alert se sont fait décimer sous obama
et ça continue sous trump avec
comment s'appelle-t-il campbellton
son nom m'échappe mais bon voilà
winner winter comment elle s'appelle
la fabrique ya encore une qui qui a été
mise en prison parce qu'elle a révélé
elle a révélé dès le rapport sur les
biens entre trompé et les russes mans
c'est en parlant tremper les russes le
rapport qui dit qu'il n'y a pas de
collusion mais on n'a pas encore eu tout
à vue de la conclusion d'un pull et 4
112 pages j'ai vu la conclusion qui a
été transmise par le gouvernement
américain
j'attends juste sur pièce ce qui est
très bien
saint thomas j'attends
ah oui mais ma vie quoi oui là pour ça
oui il faut attendre faut attendre
pareil
on va attendre
le fait qu'ils traitent les journalistes
de fox news ont pleine conférence de
presse le saindoux dingue enfin
franchement
non mais voilà on est pas si doux donne
que ces normes et
ehpad ou mais il est dingue quand même
pas s'ils donnent que simplement je
pense que c'est un fin stratège un
nom la
bombe ont discuté du vrai jack dont il
ya la question des faits qui osent
aujourd'hui c'est facile dès que
aujourd'hui on pense à nous dire 'faites
music news mais en fait les plus grands
pourvoyeurs de péquenots c'est quand
même les politiques mais j'ai vu
d'articles mediapart a pris le temps de
parler tes copains ouais oui mais voilà
je vote il enfin quand on voit par
exemple pour la faire benalla ils ont re
trafic et des vidéos pour faire croire
qu'enfin vert donc je dire les plus gros
pourvoyeurs de cette news j'ai à dire
c'est quand même les politiques quand
ils voient des interviews après pour
rappeler sa communication politique
enfin entre communication politique
effect news des fois il ya ça se
recoupent
le doigt sur les faits que nous non mais
ça va je trouve ça enfin en même temps
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire jacques enfin les gros
pourvoyeurs de fait que nous c'est les
politiques mais c'est vrai que c'est un
outil qui fait voilà c'est ça que
j'allais dire c'est un problème aussi
quand même qu'ils aient des officines je
ne sais pas comment les nommer
des pseudo journalistes ou même
d'ailleurs on a le temps on peut se
tromper aussi elle même dans les
rédactions même dans des des journaux
très reconnu il ya le droit à l'erreur
quand même mais c'est vrai que ça pose
un problème quand même ces officines qui
kiffent qui font de l'info kid qui font
des faits que nous quoi laisser pousser
leur vole leur truc de jeux pan de
gençay je veux le pilote speed d'octobre
oui enfin je parle de tout ce qu'on voit
et qui équipe qui pose vraiment un souci
parce qu'après les gens ne sont pas
alors les gens tu me dis qu'ils cessent
eux qui vont l'élire ou les voir et qui
sont pas capables de savoir si c'est
vrai pas vrai et tout ça crée une
défiance d'une manière générale et où il
ya une perte de confiance bien autant de
confusion dont l'esprit critique des
gens c'est fait pourquoi ça c'est
défendre y en a marre là il y en a qu il
faut enfin moi j'en étais moi j'en ai
été victime à j'étais en janvier 2012 en
syrie au moment où tu cherches aussi
ouais c'est ça cherchez les emmerdes on
est d'accord on s'est pris des obus sur
la gueule écueil journaliste de france 2
envoyé spécial a été tué voilà donc et
bien après il ya eu un article sur un
site réseau volt c'est je confonds pas
vous vers voltaire et réseau réseau
voltaire est-ce que ça ces messieurs
voilà donc qui a fait un site en
expliquant on était tous les
journalistes on se connaissait pas enfin
il y avait une équipe de france 2 mais
il ya plein d'autres journalistes en
expliquant ton était toute une équipe de
la djs et que gilles jacquier le
journaliste a été tué était notre chef
et ses abrutis ont fait un article pour
expliquer qu'on était tous une équipe de
la djs plutô t pas crédible non mais non
mais non parce que hier technique un
trou crédit peut te dire c'est hyper
dangereux parce que bon c'était
justement des fakes news pour
discréditer la france mais qu'en même
temps il partage son temps il est
souvent basée à damas enfin donc voilà
et puis
derrière j'ai dire que de besoin de ces
deux guides ouais enfin bon lui lui est
vraiment pas clean voilà donc là il
écrivait vraiment n'importe quoi
et on ne peut strictement rien faire et
en plus c'est même pas diffamatoires
d'être accusé d'être un agent taneja il
peut pas le plus il peut pas le prouver
essai du match sauvées est-ce que tant
de gens de neige voilà c'est ça
c'est hyper dangereux après c'est hyper
dangereux parce que moi après j'ai fait
des reportages suis allé en libye je
suis allé en tunisie le filtre ita est
bien le problème c'est que si les gens
tapent non non alors maintenant c'est
passé c'est vieux et si gens tapent nom
et tombe là dessus j'ai dire s'il perd
dangereux ça mais notre programme et
notre vie en danger et c'est ça qui est
ça que des fois des films cinq et on
vient et d'un dj sous voilà c'est ça les
grilles étaient les gens voilà non mais
c'est à dire dont ils se rendent pas
compte que ces abrutis que c'est quand
même très dangereux pour les autres
d'écrire des choses qu'est ce que tu as
lu son article qu'est ce qui lui a donné
cette intime conviction que ses deux
meilleurs pas intimes convictions
c'était de la propagande
parce qu'en fait la question il est
vraiment de la propagande pro ben asher
parce qu'en fait on ne sait toujours pas
qui est à l'origine des tirs il ya plein
de choses bizarres et donc là il est
vraiment il a toujours fait des choses
de propagande et un objectif aussi
c'était de démolir la politique
étrangère française enfin voir ils ont
indiqué jocelyne complotistes non mes
yeux une ligne complotistes enfin voilà
c'est pas un site d'information c'est
pas des journalistes ces mecs c'est ça
le problème et pourtant à dire une
audience mais c'est pas des journalistes
mais serge y explique cette audience je
pense qu'il ya toujours des gens quand
on leur parle de complotisme et que tout
est caché et tout ça et bien il ya les
gens regard des gens ça leur parle et en
même temps il existe visiter l'ancien
émir ou laisser un boulevard à ça
oui et non et parce qu'en même temps
j'ai à dire quand nous on dit il ya des
choses cachées qu'on révèle dans
journaliste d'investigation nous on le
fait sur des pièces c'est ça que les
journalistes c'est qu'on le fait pas sur
des démons le fait parce que on a des
documents ou des témoignages sérieux qui
prouvent des faits et donc effectivement
on leur dit on va vous dévoiler des
choses qui sont cachés qu'on n'a pas
voulu vous raconter que vous sachiez pas
on peut nous acculer les complotistes
mais la différence entre les deux c'est
nous derrière il ya des faits il ya des
documents il ya des témoignages des
choses qu'on recourt plusieurs sources
et on arrive à quelque chose et on est
responsable de ce qu'on écrit 10 lui
c'est un
père dépeint par un pont où ils
faisaient tu sais quoi c'est une
opération déstabilisation l a pas fait
correctement son travail à des lobbys
qui ad c'est quoi clairement j'ai déjà
gagné de toute façon des lobbys ça c'est
sûr après c'est vrai que le sujet il est
trés il est complexe comme d'habitude
donc comme toute la lumière n'est pas
faite dessus voilà et c'est disons qu'il
ya une ouverture là pour pour
s'engouffrer pour effectivement commencé
à casser du sucre sur élise lucet qui
finalement pour le coup elle a un vrai
pouvoir aujourd'hui en tant que
journaliste à la télé est la vrai
pouvoir de nuisance dont je suis aux
bisous
je ne savais pas
voilà un bisou
jamais dès qu'il ya des failles dès
qu'il ya des doutes et qu'il ya des
grosses boîtes en face jean monsanto et
tout ça c'est des grosses boîtes il
s'engouffre sur la moindre faille sur la
moindre chose pour essayer de
décrédibiliser le travail des
journalistes d'investigation j'ai dit il
ya une entre guillemets une sorte de
guerre de l'information j'ai dire il ya
des gens qui voient là qui est où ils
ont des gros gros moyens par rapport au
journal et tu disais que ça venait des
journalistes moi je pense quand même
internet c'est un bouquet du tube come
on se moquera je suis autant de temps
non mais internet et de c'est un grand
boulevard de liberté donc ça quelque
part c'est ça cet espace qui est pris
par justement ce genre d'officine et c
est là pour le coup il faut vraiment que
les gens qui est une formation qui se
rendent compte qu'il faut qu'il fasse
gaffe à ce qu'ils lisent et que avant de
lire quelque chose et d'y croire se
demander si vraiment un quelle est la
source qui est-ce qui s qui publie ce
hacker qui sont ces gens qui sont en
train de me de me donner ce genre
d'information est ce que vraiment je
peux les écouter parce que c'est vrai
après c'est un brouhaha terry et
finalement les gens ne m'aiment pas ce
qu'on peut pas dire qu'on est mal
informé en france c'est pas vrai faut
pas exagérer non c'est pas vrai il ya
géré non non mais je vois bien que tu
vois là tu en deux lignes et voilà tu en
doute non il ya l'information le
problème c'est justement ce tri comment
on fait pour trier pour voir qui vous
fait pour vous informer c'est quoi vous
vos cadeaux je sais que toi tu dire cela
mais nous on n'est qu'un reflet north
bay on jouait pour info
je crois qu'il ya une part des médias
traditionnels enfin voila vous sur un an
des lectures sur internet voilà après
pour des trucs très spécifique pour
aller chercher des petites informations
twitter on peut suivre des gens qui sont
dans des coins très particulier donc
après on évalue si la personne est bonne
ou pas bonne ou même si elle est pour un
con mais si on sait qu'elle parle pour
tel quand un bal bas pour tel camp et
puis ensuite le camp d'en face et puis
comme ça on arrive à avoir des
informations avant qu'elle soit dans
l'est dans les médias enfin pour
s'informer si on suit certains sujets
puis après ben les ressources et à nos
sources quand on travaille sur certains
sites avons fait pour protéger les
sources
c'est de plus en plus compliqué on voit
bien d'ailleurs avec c'est rigolo parce
que tout le monde dit assange grands
acteurs etc machin truc
ça merde et quand même parce que tel
c'est s'est fait alpaguer donc
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui à part l ai
donné rendez vous dans un lieu public
avec beaucoup de bruit et beaucoup de
monde et même comme ça en forêt et en
état fort et n'ayant pas de téléphone ma
chance et ça vient ça devient vraiment
compliqué
vous continuez sur la protection des
sources non
question d'internet quels sont les
rapports entre la presse locale et les
barons locaux
oui jacques qui va répandre
la presse locale effectivement le
problème c'est que la presse locale elle
fait l'info fait dire il n'y aura pas
d'arrivée à la rigueur c'est elle qui la
fera s'il ya un gros truc les fruits
c'est beaucoup aujourd'hui
ça couvre le territoire ça que moi je
trouve que ça couvre les grandes
nouvelles passent par la sp pourquoi en
afrique on appelle
les agences france propagande
sceau de la caisse et des gens
est-ce que la fp et la voix de son
maître
pas uniquement je pense pas c'est beau
c'est plus compliqué que je me fais
c'est que ça parce que tu attends tu as
dans la fp pas mal de journalistes qui
seraient ils font vraiment leur boulot
qui sont sur place dans des terrains
quand même compliqué et c'est enfin là
il ya des bureaux dans certains pays
d'afrique un bon voilà les mecs ils sont
riches que leur peau pour assez
compliqué voilà de sortir d'un faux bond
il le font donc oui après parfois tu
peux avoir effectivement une info qui a
un peu plus poussée qu'une autre parce
que c'est sûr que c'est un canal de
communication c'est un gouvernement
aussi bien sûr comme france 24 comme
rtcomm tous ces gens enfin voilà ce sont
des trucs d'état mais pour venir avec
les barons locaux effectivement réduire
les journalistes locaux sont en première
ligne avec les barons locaux donc le moi
je vois bien j'ai été confronté veut
dire le maire le président du conseil
général comment on les voit très
facilement la question c'est comment on
arrive à avoir à la fois des relations
de bon voisinage et de collaboration
pour avoir les infos de base et puis à
la fois comme on dit on aussi libre de
les critiquer et ça c'est vrai que après
le problème c'est que il ya la crainte
par rapport à la publicité et puis il
yal en fait aussi beaucoup de médias
locaux qui sont très légaliste j'ai à
dire c'est à partir du moment où on
critique pas trop l'omert
parce que c'est le pouvoir et du coi est
donc le problème de médias locaux c'est
que ils sont plutôt légaliste et que par
rapport à l'investigation en fait ils
n'ont pas beaucoup de temps mais c'est
pas trop leur priorité ils veulent pas
se fâcher aussi avec le pouvoir local il
ya un manque de moyens il ya des pages à
remplir hier tous les matins d'un des
pages blanches il faut remplir les
patchs et le plus simple c'est d'aller
au point presse de faire quelques trucs
et on peut ils n'ont pas forcément les
ressources humaines aussi pour aller
faire le véritable travail
d'investigation
c'est pour ça que par exemple il ya des
confrères médiacité qu'un qui est un
mediapart en fait
local d'investigations locales ils font
le boulot que souvent la presse locale
ne fait pas faux que mon prochain livre
bah pareil alors haussé sur abonnement
voilà est un peu trop de funding ils ont
eu quelques mediapart a mis un petit peu
d'argent départ aussi voilà et ça c'est
des gens qui cherchent à faire le boulot
que la presse locale fait pas assez
voire pas du tout mais sait on en
revient finalement est ce qu'on disait
tout au début c'est la proximité en fait
le problème c'est vrai que voilà et
c'est avec les journalistes politiques
c'est la proximité qui fait que c'est
compliqué parce qu'effectivement une
fois qu'on connaît les gens ben quand on
les connaît quand on les côtoie tous les
jours c'est quand même un peu compliqué
d'aller d'aller fouiner et comme disait
jacques aller chercher la merde c'est
compliqué c'est tout simplement humain
on se connaît c'est pas si simple que ça
demain de faire une enquête sur ces
interviews et les coquettes surdoué qui
aura eu la copine de ta copine qui veut
chez nous oui mais il était plus tôt il
était plus tôt il était plutôt sympa à
l'article ouais je sais pas si c'était
sympa c'était factuel c'est ni méchant
ni sympa
c'est vrai les plus gros barons locaux
c'est les entreprises ce que ça a été
changé son article ça a été changée par
la direction du monde 48 ans après ou 24
heures après la publication papier ils
ont ajouté trois phrases pour nous
éclabousser la tête elle a fait retirer
sa signature parce qu'il lui avait pas
demandé il avait laissé sa signature à
l'or papier et échanger et sur les deux
trois choses qui étaient avec elle était
pas d'accord parce qu'elle avait fait
une enquête de terrain qu'il allait
rencontrer les gens que ça ait pris du
temps qu'il connaissait le board avec lé
débat quand
on aura une vengeance avec jean paul ça
prendra le temps que ça prenant des
briquets de poche va bien se passer
autre question d'internet quand vous
êtes rencontrés
par le collectif au fait en fait moi je
suis partie des cheveux partie des
fondateurs du collectif extra muros est
donc un moment on avait mille des
petites annonces sur des forums de voilà
est donc en disant on cherchait des
journalistes intéressés par d'autres
modèles et par le désir de travailler
ensemble votre ferr d'investigation de
faire des reportages or voilà et de
partager des moyens et tout et c'est
comme ça que stéphanie nous a contactés
et en toi tu sais même plus penser comme
moi je suis venu par un ami commun enfin
qui aiderait dans le collectif parier
homologues
qu'est ce qui vous rapproche dans votre
votre approche du métier
approche du métier non mais pour le coup
c'est vraiment d'aller essayer de faire
une investigation salir enquêter noeud
papillon la vraie info voilà il faut
sortir la vraie info parce que sinon on
est je pense qu'on est
voilà on est on est quand même
relativement différent on traite pas les
mêmes sujets mais c'est cette envie
d'aller plus loin quoi ne pas s'en tenir
à ce qu'on nous raconte tout je rebondis
sur ce que tu veux dire quels sont vos
spécificités à chacun
moi je fais finalement quand même pas
mal de sécurité routière en dehors de
l'investigation et sur l'investigation
c'est vraiment l'argent public les
marchés publics qui m'intéresse moi j'ai
pas mal travaillé sur les questions de
terrorisme
de défense voilà et puis or la
corruption puisque j'ai fait un bouquin
le tour de france de la corruption donc
c'est un peu mais suffisant
mais écoute et spécialités
je crois que c'est un peu tout ce qui
est technique liées à la surveillance de
masse
l'insécurité informatique
ces choses là et après effectivement
j'ai pas mal bossé notamment avec
jacques sur les questions de terrorisme
voilà
que pensez vous toujours en question
internet que pensez-vous des
journalistes d'opinion par rapport au
journalisme d'investigation par exemple
alors quel est le phénomène le plus
présent dans les journaux la censure ou
l'auto censure l'autocensure
clairement la ceinture elle est très
rare quoi connu bon voilà les ailes et
quand même pas l'inversé un petit peu je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'auto censure
et que c'est surtout l'autocensure que
les journalistes isa maintien si je
pourrai pas puis gatel actionnaires ou
yat le patron des proches d'intel et
tout ça alors que des fois il a rien
demandé et un exemple à de nous trois
l'exemple du point enfin voila depuis
les halles preuve peut-être d'autres des
exemples cyril hanouna qui fait retire
un papelard
oui mais franchement nous en
l'occurrence est vraiment à la marge
c'est arrivé là l'histoire que jacques
froissant le point voilà ouais moi je
n'étais pas de la censure mais c'est une
conséquence c'était quand je travaillais
à l'agefi
visa les cartes bancaires c'est une
associée à l'époque c'est une
association de banques invité la presse
pour un raout annuel tous les ans une
première année j'y vais c'est bien super
bien on est super bien logés ça se
passait dans un pays étranger donc un
petit voyage tous à déloger son gardien
non ya pas de petit peu de fraises rien
mais tu est très bien logé tu voyages
très très bien et donc on
une première année truc super
intéressant vraiment des conférences
passionnantes ils font venir des gens
super deuxième année je me dis c'était
bien la première année j'ai fait pas mal
d'articles pour dire que c'était bien
deuxième année je me dis bon bah je
filmerai invite j'y retourne
il se passe rien aucune conférence
intéressante c'était le vide sidéral
quand je suis rentré en fait j'ai fait
j'avais une enquête en cours sur les
moyens de sécurisation des paiements sur
internet à l'époque c'était tellement
vieux et c'est cette tout ça c'était pas
voilà donc il y avait un projet qui
s'appelait se tait et je titre en
attendant elle se tait et j'explique que
ça marchera jamais mais vraiment je lis
ça ça jamais ça va marcher n'a pas été
évité alors un j'ai pas été réinvité et
pendant six mois plus personne le
journal ne pouvait avoir quelqu'un chez
visa pas que moi plus personne il
répondait plus non vous on va prendre
parle plus
bon après au bout d'un moment ils se
sont rendu compte que quand même il
avait besoin de faire passer des
messages parce que le journal était
tellement spécialisée est tellement à
destination des financiers etc sont ni
ne pas se couper complètement à ton
patron de l'époque revenait au bout de
trois semaines vous aurez coûte très
cher on a dégagé ce vilain petit canard
qui a écrit en un an je pense que ça
serait pas ça aurait pas calmé les
esprits
c'était vraiment c'était très peu de
pain sur ce cas en particulier c'était
très emmerdant pour blizzard s'est
présenté en vain pour les banques ce
papier parce que y miser énormément là
dessus et tu avais par exemple en france
il y avait deux tops managers de chaque
banque qui étaient grassement payé pour
travailler à 100% sur ce projet là
l'idée c'était de faire un système de
sécurisation des paiements sur internet
qui reposait sur la carte bancaire c'est
très compliqué il ya beaucoup de crypto
et de machins dire que ça n'allait
jamais marché c'était mettre en cause en
fait tout ce qu'ils avaient fait jusque
là il n'était pas content du tout donc
j'ai encore une tripotée de questions
dont je vais vous envoyer une salve et
puis on va passer à autre chose est-ce
que vous avez travaillé sur les données
de wikileaks premiers pas ce qui vous
est arrivé d'avoir peur pour votre
sécurité dans l'une ou plusieurs de vos
enquêtes
hop hop hop commençer de cette situation
de possession des journaux parlés
milliardaire ça c'est quelque chose qui
revient souvent
est ce que vous cherchez des profils
particuliers pour vos projets
allez hop vous choisissez une chacun
alors wikileaks
c'est vraiment parce que je préparais un
papier pour reflet pour écrire cette
histoire de l'arrestation d'assange non
je me suis replongé un peu dans les
trucs que j'avais écrit à très longtemps
et je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
écrit des trucs pour dire que
l époque
que wikileaks s'embourgeoiser
c'était un de mes papiers dans son
ancien site avant 2011 donc
au début ils ont balancé toutes les
infos comme ça en vrac et débrouillez
vous fouillez chercher essayer d'en
tirer quelque chose et puis après
sans doute sous la pression de la santé
il ya eu une espèce de il s'est rendu
compte du pouvoir qu'il avait
vis-à-vis de la presse et il a imposé en
fait de donner les infos ou une partie
des infos à un certain nombre de
journaux choisis mme de télé choisi par
wikileaks et du coup on fait ça à
repasser par le prisme de la presse qui
fait que ben dans la presse on est
obligé de faire des choix parce qu'on ne
peut pas tout traiter du coup il y avait
plein de trucs qui a été laissé de côté
mais dont qui n'étaient pas publics et
que les gens ne pouvaient pas creusé par
eux mêmes donc voilà avec cablegate
j'avais regardé au début en gros bout de
quelques jours tu avais 200 câble qui
avaient été publiées sur des milliers
quoi donc c'était vraiment un masque
parce que l'un des marges cloud bah non
c'est pas fou le disque genre donc donc
à partir de ce moment où ils ont choisi
travailler avec certains journaux
choisis et bien ben non il n'était pas
possible de travailler sur les documents
de wikileaks mixte alors les
milliardaires oui je pense effectivement
c'est un vrai problème quand il ya des
milliardaires qui sont propriétaires de
journaux il ya un prennent de conflit
d'intérêts alors j'ai dire surtout qui à
certains pays par exemple en angleterre
où il ya vraiment haut niveau une
liberté éditoriale c'est à dire que ça
ne viendra même pas l'idée aux
propriétaires et influencer sur la
rédaction mais on sait qu'en france et
c'est pas le cas voilà bernard arnault
tout ça
attention c'est pas tellement qu'elle
est la solution là ils vont de façon la
presse écrite va tellement mal que c'est
ce qui passe à sa méthode vous mourir
peut-être donc voilà une fois non mais
c'est un vrai problème c'est un vrai ils
vont pas bien mais y reçoivent combien
de ligue 2 roues
république oui bien sûr d'être ces 100
millions c'est pourquoi bien je sais
trop où ces chiffres sont publiés tous
les ans et ça c'est public c'est quand
même un sacré paquet de pognon oui c'est
un paquet de pognon oui mais quand on
fait du papier ça coûte très cher quand
on à l'imprimerie la diffusion
aujourd'hui presstalis enfin toutes les
prestataires pour livrer des journaux
dans les kiosques et tout ça ça coûte
une fortune le papier coûte cher ben
voilà donc vrai dire il ya beaucoup de
sous mais il ya un côté beaucoup de
dépenses sont là et on voit quand même
que les dépenses pour les reportages
pour les enquêtes y taille d'abord la
cua
vous n'arrivez la fin de notre interview
je vous cherchez des profils
particuliers donc ça vous intéresse pas
quand même question des profits comme de
journalistes et
vous invitent tu dois voir quelques
élèves auraient alors de janvier en fait
en fait nous on est rodé crif au déjà
dire on a un collectif actuellement des
23 donc on est vraiment foule n'est
qu'en fin du iii ou d'un saut vous
n'êtes pas en aviez donc voilà on a des
photographes des gens qui font date et
les des gens qui font de la radio des
gens qui font de la presse écrite voilà
par contre s'il ya des journalistes qui
veulent nous contacter déjà donc des
gens qui ont envie de fonder des
collectifs nous on reçoit souvent des
jeunes ou moins jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils
disent ben nous on aimerait bien fonder
un collectif est ce que vous pouvez nous
parler de notre expérience votre
expérience et tout ça donc ça on est
tout à fait open pour partager parce
qu'elle sait que pense que c'est
l'avenir c'est quoi le lieu pour donner
du pognon pour vous tous cas alors le
lien donc c'est sûr l oiseau et donc il
ya un lien cours qui est bit.ly slash
reflet au pluriel tv
je pense que ce sera mis en ligne on
tape lots aso et reflets avec as et on
tombe dessus
d'accord c'est des gens venus chez nous
et
la dernière question qui n'est pas une
question cdc un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et puis comme vous êtes 3d
conseillé à chacun un livre
donc un conseil pour les jeunes
générations à daniel
antoine battut et rompus à cet exercice
montre le chat botté petit copain
un livre pas les bras un livre je dirais
le lite et rateront
qui laisse car pitt je crois
qu'ils aient un bouquin passionnant sur
le bullshit en fait que peuvent générer
les sources justement et voilà comment
embobiner les gens avec un générateur de
bullshit
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
réfléchissez
bah oui et non parce que c'est un métier
qui devient quand même difficile qui est
fatiguant qui rapportent très peu c'est
vraiment tu l'as dit c'est un sacerdoce
quoi donc voilà c'est parce que tu as
une vraie
je pense que tu fais ça parce que tu as
tu as une vraie vocation quoi voilà donc
vous profite aussi pour dire nous aussi
on aboutit pee wee sont poursuivies
pendant financé par d'autres communautés
jacques un bouquin conseil pour les
jeunes générations un bouquin
lelangue aux deux je crois que c'est
philippe lançon le journaliste du canard
qui s'est pris une balle de kalachnikov
au visage et qui raconte tout son chemin
de reconstruction voilà je trouve que ça
fait ça fait réfléchir enfin sa salive
ramon touchant mais voilà donc je pense
qu intéressant à lire et voilà c'est un
choix humain enfin voilà d'un confrère
voilà
conseil pour les jeunes générations bon
je n'aime pas conseil ça fait vieux con
quand stéphanie
mois sur les conseils du j'ai du mal
aussi c'est vraiment voilà
le journal je suis assez d'accord avec
antoine quoi je ne suis pas sûr en
boucle de le conseiller part à mes
enfants le bouquin chez pas à la rigueur
on pourrait lire l'aca d'actualité lire
le bouquin de revin quand il était sorti
d'école ça c'était comment les nouveaux
chiens de garde ou je ne sais plus
comment ça s'appelait exactement chaude
ou de hrw à rufin ouais tu as un petit
peu et en fait quelqu'un des scooters
nous oui
quelque part il était non mais c'est pas
inintéressant et c'est d'actualité
puisque mais même se retrouve maintenant
politique et finalement il fustigeait un
peu les rédactions qui était à la botte
des politiques donc voilà donc qu'est ce
que vous pensez de pire car
ça c'était
moi en tout cas ça a baigné tout nouveau
cd méthodes journalistiques qui sont
intéressantes voilà c'est une bonne
chose ça a baigné ce pour quoi
éventuellement en ce qui me concerne
pour qu'on est devenu journée merci
d'être venu nous voir ce soir là mais
rappelle que vous êtes sur le cous doc
sur de l'argent public qui ça va piquer
et donc merci d'être venus et nous ont
parlé prochaine merci
[Musique]